welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
uh first please mute yourself during the
talk uh but if you have question you can
unmute and ask questions uh or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end uh second today's ddps seminar is
open to external audience uh therefore
no classifi discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally The Talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel that's about it now let
me briefly introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host Dr uh Marius gin
Hofer who received his PhD from the
University of fryberg Germany where he
researched multi physics models for bone
growth under the supervision of
Professor Patrick dond
he then served as a post-doctoral
research fellow at simula research
laboratory in Oso Norway focusing on
scientific machine learning with
Professor Kent Andra model currently he
is a researcher at the University uh
Hospital fryberg specializing in AI for
healthc care his ongoing research
interests include error analysis and
optimization of neural network based
methods for solving p paral differential
equations today Marius will talk about
infinite dimensional optimization for
scientific machine learning I'm sure we
are going to hear a wonderful talk uh
before I pass the button to Marius as a
traditional tradition to the ddps
seminar let me ask a somewhat informal
question so that we can um we we know
something something something about
Mario um some out of the the technical
reason so I happen to know you are very
uh Keen to guitar playing um if you can
share your favorite piece favorite music
uh you would like to play that's that's
a difficult question it
changes yes
um well let's just go with the classics
which is Stairway to Heaven by let
zeppin oh okay I'm nonar as a non-ar
player I never heard of that but oh you
you can it's it's a good one you can you
can check it out okay I will definitely
check it out well thank you Marius the
St is yours thank you thank you for the
nice introduction and let's get
started so today I'll talk about um
optimization for scientific machine
learning and
talk will be structured in roughly two
parts first um that's the specialty sort
of of our approach is the functions
based perspective on the optimization
for IML problem problems and um what I
will propose to you is for these kind of
problems to adopt an infinite
dimensional Viewpoint or a continuous
Viewpoint um leaving out the anset class
and then develop optimizer or choose
optimizers um based on the infinite um
the properties on the on the function
Space level and then discretize in a
certain way that guarantees you that you
mimic the function space Dynamic and
with this principle in mind we'll see
how um how we can design new
algorithms and also understand existing
ones um from that
perspective and then in the next step um
with the after designing these
optimization methods we'll have a look
into how you can scale them to large
scale neuron networks we'll do that with
um one specific
strategy where we use the chronical
structure of the linear layer jacobians
in the neuron networks the talk is
mainly based on these two papers I've
linked um here below um one position
paper this year's icml and then a recent
one which is related to um the second
part which is about The Chronic Factor
approximation um so let's dive
in let's start with the function space
optimization and let's clarify um sort
of what kind of problems I want to talk
about I said scientific machine learning
and for me or at least for this talk
mainly what I have in mind is um
operator learning
but also um methods for Shing us
equation the electron Shing equation
with a network
anets can be physics and formular
networks formulations of partial
differential equations or inverse
problems could be deep rits so rational
formulations essentially anything that
involves pte terms in the loss function
and real networks the methods will um be
well suited for all of them
and one
observation the starting point also for
our work in this direction is that as
soon as you introduce pdes to objective
functions um the neuron Network training
gets more difficult let me give you an
illustration of that statement that um
optimization in siml can be quite
hard I have two pictures here for you
details are not so important let's look
at the first one here
I've taken this from um a recent paper
the forward laion paper so in this paper
they solve the many electron shinger
equation um when I what I want to stress
here is the sheer amount of GPU hours
that I used for single solve is in the
in the thousands almost towards 10,000
GPU for single problem um and then the
other paper is a very simple it's just a
two-dimensional for
equation and with a smooth solution you
formulated use the pin formulation and
you optimize green is just um full badge
gradient descent where and red is adom
and you see huge amount of iterations
and you see stagnating
errors
so what we are going to do here is to
abandon first order
optimization and look into the structure
on the infinite dimensional spaces we
want to exploit the geometry that is
induced by the PD operators to this to
design smarter
algorithms
and I have an informal road map here for
you how how to do that I I call it first
optimize then
discretize so we're given a siml problem
and later also under Network anss and
the first thing um we need to do is
think about the continuous formulation
so we need to formulate a minimization
problem let's say it's a minimization
problem it could be sadle points root
finding whatever so it's a minimization
problem in a Hilbert space H that's a
function space here so e the energy
that's what we want to minimize so we
need clarity about how that should look
like and then after we formulated our
problem we'll have a look in what are
the properties of e right and here it's
left abstract there is no properties
assumed but in a practical application
it will have properties and based on
these properties on function space we'll
decide for an appropriate
algorithm said an appropriate iterative
algorithm in function space what I mean
by that is you update um your current
iterate by a Direction and you
step until you're happy with it right
but remember this is in function space
this is nothing you can you can
practically do and to get something back
which is which you can do in practice
which you can do on your machine then
you need to discretize but note this
this is the last step and discretization
here what I propose is to project the
update Direction this would be dek on
the tension space of your Nur Network
anets or on whatever your anet is if
it's not their networks it's also
fine um so let's let us put that uh make
that concrete with a very very simple
example the the example is as simple as
it can possibly be arguably so suppose
um we want to solve posal equation on
some domain Omega we have some forcing
data we have some boundary conditions
um that's the starting
point
then I reformulate the equation in this
case as a minimization problem I've
chosen here the simplest one this would
be physics and form networks
formulation but of course you could
choose a VAR a variational formulation
or you could formulate it as a root
finding
problem um but let's stick with this so
I've I've chosen here the Hilbert space
is H2 this is how it
looks no unid class no nothing just a
pure
formulation and then the next step is
where we decide um what optimization
algorithm is appropriate for this kind
of of energy so let's have a look the PD
is
linear and we use l L2 squar around the
residual so that makes this um energy
quadratic so it's a quadratic function
on function space and as we all know
Newton's method for
minimization builds at every at where
you at at your current itate it builds a
quadratic model of your objective
function in it minimizes that quadratic
model so Newton's method in function
space for this energy has one step
conversions no matter where you
start and if I write out Newton's method
function space this is the way it looks
like here is the Fret derivative of our
function space guide this lives in the
Dual
space here is the hen this is a bilinear
form or alternatively it Maps um from
the Primal to the Dual space this is the
same thing essentially and that's how it
that's how it looks
like um and if your energy looks
different you would probably choose
something else than you we'll see in
example soon and still no unet class
this is coming now now it's time to
discretize now it's time when you choose
your
ANS um and I left the anets um generic
these you could think of them as neural
networks but you could also think of
them as finite element functions both is
covered by by um the theory then the
tension
space is given by the partial
derivatives um with respect to the
parameters of our aess
class and the
objective the object that we're actually
minimizing which is not no longer Post
in function space but Post in parameter
space um this L is the Lost function and
it's just pulling back our function
space energy or parameter space Capital
Theta and then we discretize Newton's
method and what do I mean by
discretise I mean we use this linear
space right this tangent space we use it
to do a gurin a discretization of this
bilinear form right this is just the
second derivative of e at U Theta this
would be our current
itate um this gives us a matrix
G and then we discretize this guy here
too in a gurin sense right this comes
from a dual space this is like your
forcing in a finite element sense and
this is nothing but the ukian gradient
of the
loss um and then if I then just freely
translate from muttin and function space
to what I just did with this galeran
discretization um I arrive at an
optimization algorithm in parameter
space which is
computable here I introduced also um a
step size here this is sort of the
analog of uh The hessen Matrix in
this guy dagger denotes a pseudo inverse
because I do not know whether these guys
are linearly dependent or not here's the
ukle and
gradient so to make That explicit tying
back to the example we had before this
was our energy then this Matrix
G looks like this right we have the form
with the llusion coming from this term
here and we have the boundary conditions
coming from here
and now it's time to implement and see
how it
does um and it performs very well so
this um what I've just shown you is the
is the green line here the problem is
again um a pant problem to be consistent
with um the explanation before um and
the formulation right was the pin
formulation and maybe if you've played
around with physics and form networks is
sometimes quite hard to optimize them
it's certainly very hard to get
acceptable or very high accuracies and
here we see um a relative L2 error and
of course on a test set of points not on
the ones we've trained on going down to
10 minus 7 sometimes we see 10 to the
minus 8 and no other method that we've
tested and can come
close so um why why do I call that
Energy natural gradient descent that's
because when we first discovered this
that you could actually optimize pins
quite well um we had a slightly
different perspective we came from a
natural gradient
perspective and we thought about the hen
as a remanion metric and later we
realized that you can
derive this algorithm from this infinite
dimensional Viewpoint that I've just
shown you um and since this was just one
example I we tested it on on a bunch of
of of linear equations also we use the
first order reformulation time dependent
ones
and it works really well for all of
them we do some tricks of course I mean
we do a stabilization lburg Market kind
of stabilization and so on but um we can
get um very good accuracies with small
networks already for three-dimensional
pdes and the training time is not
horrible can be seconds to minutes
depending on on your setup and your
GPU um so now to really drive that idea
home that you can start from the from
the infinite dimensional Viewpoint
I I want to show a different example
which is a nonlinear pte and a your
Stokes
equation with where we will um choose a
different algorithm on function space to
begin with we'll choose gaus Newton's
algorithm on function space
and so if this is the pde and again we
use um a residual
formulation um and for Simplicity we we
ignore that we should add a Divergence
penalty and the boundary penalty here
let's just look at this
um then this is our
formulation and then we can ask okay how
should we optimize that um objective
function in function space
then you see it's a non it is nonlinear
inside here so it loses the convexity in
function space because of this
nonlinearity but it certainly is a
nonlinearly squares problem and if you
want to solve nonlinearly squares
problem a good choice is gaus Newton's
method or lab Mar's method and we do
that in function space so it looks like
this you have the linearization of the
residual after it the adjoined and
that's what you want to in
word um andless it's just for
completeness the formula how this form s
looks like
and you choose an
answers U Theta Pepi for velocity and
pressure the answer is again same
notation as
before the tangent space is um again the
linearization and and then you
discretize gaus algorithm again using a
gurin aners so you you get back a matrix
G and this is your ukian um
gradient this is how you get the entries
of the Matrix so you insert your basis
vectors from your gin space that you
chose in the form um and again you're
left with an optimization algorithm
which now in this line looks exactly as
before but of course this Matrix G comes
from a different infinite dimensional
optimization
algorithm and
again this works better than than any
other Optimizer we could we could find
and then we tried this is um an unsteady
3D belami flow we could get accuracy
close to single Precision um we couldn't
get 10 to the minus 10 as before but
it's still better by a margin than than
any everything else
so to sort of come to a conclusion here
is that you you can use this principle
that I've showed you and you can start
with different uh different function
space um algorithms and translate them
and as a matter of fact
um they often relate to a known
optimization method in parameter space I
haven't shown you this before but when I
introduced Newton
and if you do the computations you can
find out what you're actually doing in
parameter space is a generalized gaus
Newton
method um or if you're solving a saddle
point problem this is the lon Newton
method so you have a you have a
constraint optimization problem you use
laon
formalism you take um you take the
gradient of the loran use Newton's
method to find zeros of that
gradient that's what I mean with Lor
Newton and if you discretize that in in
the way I've just shown you you end up
in certain situations with competitive
gradient descent which is proposed in a
and was proposed in a totally different
community and gaus Newton and function
space translates to gaus Newton so um I
think there's a lot to discover
still um and Marius there's a
clarification question I think it's in
slide 16 Robert is asking is that g or
inverse G in the update oh not 16 or 15
when here that the dagger is the pseudo
inverse yeah so you need you need to
invert The Matrix yes is it clear
robot okay cool yeah I'll talk more
about this Matrix and how how costly
that in Inver version is later on
because I suppose that's that's a very
very um good question to have okay
because of course there is some price
that we pay but I'll talk about I'll
talk about that
soon
um so I I want to because in the
beginning I promised that um the methods
that we derive will provably mimic
function space um Dynamics so that's
what we're setting out to to prove now
or just to look at when when this is
valid so um all the methods that I've
shown you before are of this form right
this guy is now we said right we add a
direction this is this direction and I
assume a certain structure for this
direction of a sh derivative and then
you take it back to Primal space with
the linear map with the inverse of a
linear map that might depend on your
iterate so I assume this guy T is linear
continuous
bjective um everything we've seen before
um falls into this setting we also
assume that this map T is
coercive um and if we assume that so the
technicalities of what we assumed for T
are not so critical but if we assumed
that then we can prove the following
which I call projection Theory and let
me walk you through this slide so here
is just a repetition
of uh to clarify Den notation of our
generic optimization
algorithm and if with in parameter space
we follow this algorithm right if we
step Theta 1 Theta 2 theta 3 and so on
then we can ask ourselves what is
happening on the function Space level
what what do the functions do and how do
they relate to Stepping with the
direction
DK and you can see here
that actually we are stepping exactly as
the infinite dimensional algorithm this
is the DK but there is this Pi guy with
is which is a projection and this is a
gallan projection on the tension
space and then there is an arrow which
corresponds to the step size and the
length of the step so actually this is
what I what I um mean when I refer to um
provable
that we follow the function space
Dynamics and let me give you a visual
visualization of that um of that theory
right let's just look at the first um at
the first four Images this is again Pon
equation um Simple Solution you
essentially see the solution here
because U Theta you should can this is
at initialization so this network is
almost
zero so this direction here is really
the perfect update Direction direction
if you add this guy onto your current
iterate you'll be at at Crown proof
immediately so all the other update
directions you want to match that
picture and this is Newton in function
space matches perfectly whereas Newton
and parameter space which is a different
algorithm is clueless and gradient
descent
to and the same is repeated here below
this is a kovas flow example so an a
Stokes
equation uh where Theta is now
somewhere um somewhat close to the
solution say on the order of a few
percent of relative L2 error so again
this is the perfect update
Direction and if you look what gaus
Newton and function space or Newton and
function space tell you and what they
propose to step or what they choose to
step and it matches almost perfectly in
the eyeball mod whereas Newton parameter
space or gradient descent are not um are
not promising or not good that we also
see that in the the
optimization so with that let's get to
scalability because so far I've just
shown you what works well and this
algorithms work so well you get so high
accuracy but of course there is a price
and the price is that we need to invert
a matrix in every
step um and to go back to the to the
Energy natural gradient the Newton and
function space algorithm The Matrix you
need to invert to assemble of course to
invert is the following
one this guy here but if your
anwers is um non-local then this Matrix
is
dense it is typically rank deficient and
Ill conditioned so you have a pretty a
pretty challenging Matrix to deal with
small scale small networks are fine you
can do an SVD maybe maybe because this
Matrix is positive semi-definite you
regularize it a little bit with a ticken
of regularization you had an identity
you could use use a cheski solve you'll
be fine but as soon as you scale up um
the size of the networks this is really
challenging so what are what are our
options to scale it
up you you can use a matrix fre
formulation um that works this system
needs to be solved you need access to a
matrix Vector products you can get
them um the details are for example in
this paper how to get the um Matrix
Vector products you just rely on that
you can reformulate it in param meter
space as a gaus Newton Matrix and then
you can do that you can use CG what CG
iterates for a long time because the
Matrix is ill
conditioned but at least you can scale
up a different strategy is to derive
cheap to invert
approximations and this is where I'm
going to focus on um the rest of the
talks if you take derivatives of um
linear Network
layers then you can find um chronical
structure in that Matrix and this
chronical structure can be leveraged to
build approximation of of
G and of course you can also um um aim
to to combine these two um these two
strategies you can build a GP invert
approximation use it as a preconditioner
in your
CG so let's let's get into the chronical
Factor
approximation so very um roughly what we
want to do is we have the Matrix
G and you think of your answer as a neur
networks with layers this is what this
one two capital L corresponds to and you
discard cross interaction between
layers then you're left here with with
capital L many matrices which are still
quite big and then you aim to
approximate them um as chronical
products of two smaller
matricies you approximate d as chronicus
of course be because you can you can um
change the inverse with the with the
factors and this really gives you a
dramatic um a dramatic speed up in in
solving so if you say my um my linear
map my linear layer and my network maps
from RN to RM we're ignoring biases here
then this Matrix um then the block
Matrix up here is of size n * m 2 but
the chronical factors are just n * n and
M * m so you have you have a drastic
speed up and you can scale up um by a
large
margin so how how do you get that
chronical
structure I'll show you that with an
with the um with an example um where the
laian terms so which is again motivated
from the pro was coming from the pro
equation
um so what you can show is that the
Matrix G or the layer uh the block
Matrix corresponding to a layer is of
that form so CH this is the jobian with
respect to the eelf weight
Matrix um of this expression transpose
times
itself and where you can find chronus
structure is if you take derivatives of
this map Theta now is a weight Matrix
and you map the weight Matrix to weight
Matrix times fixed
vector and if you take the Jacobian with
respect to this Matrix Theta then you'll
get chronica structure now if if you
think about chain rule what we need to
do to get out this um this chronical
structure of um in our complicated
computation graph is we need to know
what the children in the computational
graph of this map is so the E we Matrix
maap to laion of U Theta at a data
point and I'm not going to go into the
details
but what
um how we could disentangle the
structure is that we relied on forward
mode or also called tailor mode um AO
diff which is also what is um what was
recently proposed in the forward llan
paper which is from the um from The BMC
community so let's
just look at this graph think of a
multi-layer
perceptron um Theta are your trainable
weights just just ignore biases this is
a weight Matrix and we have L many this
is your input so going through here just
gives you your neural
prediction and of course the weight
Matrix enters as a matrix product to
this
Vector but of course we do not only want
to for to to um to compute the um output
of the neural network but we also want
to um compute first order derivatives
and second order derivatives possibly
more but let's focus on them so forward
mode as um in contrast to um to back
propagation you just push everything
forward right you multiply the matrices
from the from the other end so this is
what's happening here
and when you do when you write out the
recursion you see that the weight Matrix
doesn't only enter into um in the
forward propagation is a matrix product
but it does also enter in the first
derivatives do in the gradient and also
in the
laan so then if you factor this whole
thing exactly as the colors indicate
with pink and blue then you can Leverage
The chronical
structure and I really do not want to go
into detail here but this Viewpoint lets
us compute exactly how that Matrix looks
it looks horrible three sums a lot of
symbols chronical structure here so I
note this is not an approximation this
really is an
equality and then the keg um
approximation which is handwave which is
hand waving admittedly but is put into
great use in in the Deep Learning
Community is to swap the sum and the
chroner and we also he drop um indices
that are different from each other so we
really end up with an approx imation as
exactly as I promised to you so the
Matrix G can be approximated as a
chronic
b um so this was the outline it's
technical you can find the details in
our um in our recent paper which is
going to be in
NPS um and I've showed it to you for the
pon problem but it does actually work
for General nonlinear pdes with the pin
formulation you can do it for very
rational formulations the B Brits method
we haven't looked into neural operators
this requires more work so there we
uncertain how it how it would play
out and um typically once you have this
approximation for G there is a whole
bunch of bells and whistles you um put
on top of um on top of your um Optimizer
would be a trust region method for
stepsize choice you would do exponential
moving average for the kic matric you
would maybe update them infrequently so
so there are many many things you can do
and as said you find uh you find the
details it's not a pre-printed this
point anymore in in this paper
here and then I want to show you some
experiments just to illustrate that
um that uh we we keep the good
performance um or we can reproduce the
good performance in the small
experiments but we can scale to big n
works so to warm up here's again the
equation the blue lines are the methods
that do not scale right that that
require a dense Matrix that you need to
invert um the black lines are
KAC the light green um line is the CG
version of um the natural
gradient and then we have first order
methods in red and orange and lbfgs in
dark green and what you see here in the
small example this is always relative L2
error over time um the the naive way of
doing things is actually the best one
where is as soon as you scale up um this
is the dimension these are the number of
trainable weights in unal network then
um at some point you cannot do the naive
approach anymore but black lines always
are among the best performing so now we
move up in dimension we do a heat
equation in four spatial and one time
Dimension and the picture is
similar
um and finally we've we we went up to um
1 million parameters with a 100 De
forong equation actually I believe this
experiment is still running here we did
a Bas and sech for the hyper parameters
so there's a lot of lot of work that
goes into these numerical experiments
and to really fine tune these optimizers
before before then after finding good
hyper parameters they're really ready to
use so this is by no means um the end of
the of the um of the sort of Journey for
really making the best out of this
Optimizer um and then just put it in
context or put this K in context this
approximation um allows us to SK okay um
millions of parameters that works really
well um our I still call them
preliminary somewhat preliminary
numerical experience they compare
favorably to all established optimizers
often outperforming them
and you can do the approximation I've
showed you virtually to any
pte but
um it will be interesting to see more
equation we we're working on that right
now and of course maybe this is the main
point the KAC approximation is not so
easy to set up so you need a dedication
to implement that and to make it
run and with that I just want to wrap up
and
maybe give an Outlook I think of what
what I what can be done next in sort of
that
area um and where I think future work is
uh future efforts are well well
placed so I think the function space
Viewpoint is far from exploited I think
there's still many things one can do
there's many Concepts you can still
translate among them for example trust
reaching methods infin dimensional ones
or operator preconditioning
approaches I'm also not aware of any
Convergence Theory that really properly
separates the function space and the
parameter
space and
I think there's still a lot to do um on
the kayx side on just improving the
optimizer we've built we haven't really
tried to use it as a precondition and
Matrix free implementations currently
working on a high dimensional pdes like
fuer Blanc hon chobi bang equation Shing
equations I think there is a lot to come
and um with that um I want to thank you
for your attention and happy to take
questions awesome thank you so much for
the wonderful talk uh very nice very
nice um so let's have yeah yeah may I
maybe exit full screen mode so that I
see you if somebody is asking questions
or maybe that's not a good idea I'll
leave it open so that we can um go back
to slides for the questions yeah the
people can unmute themselves and then
ask questions directly and um yes let's
have a qu sessions
uh I can uh start I guess uh so for more
General nonlinear uh problems you switch
from the Newton to uh Galos Newton uh is
it because you know to avoid um you know
the Computing the full Hasan
informations because that some I can I
can tell you um why we do why we do that
so when the um when the objective is
nonconvex of course you have no
guarantee that your um Newton Matrix is
definite right it could be indefinite MH
and um then you have no guarantee that
the what you step is actually a descent
Direction um only if you get close to um
to the minimizer then you know that um
Newton's Matrix will get um definite MH
um and when we do the numeric
experiments we we observe precisely that
if we use Newton in function space right
and discretize it that way and uh and
step then it's not stable it doesn't go
in the right direction but if we're
close to the minimum and use Newton then
it is very close to gaus Newton in
function space which is also to expected
to be expected and we found gaus Newton
just to be the more robust um choice
because you always because you linearize
you always have the guarantee that
you're taking it decent
Direction um cool very nice uh not just
for you know avoid the avoiding the
implementation converson but it does
actually yeah I mean because you compute
the the second the Newton Matrix right
the the infinite dimensional object is
always something that you compute with
pen and
paper so there is there is maybe a
little bit it's maybe a little bit more
difficult to compute with on pen and
paper the Newton Matrix than to compute
the gaus Newton Matrix but it's
comparable and implementation is maybe
an epsylon more difficult for the Newton
Matrix but you can do both but the
performance of the gaus Newton is just
more
stable okay wonderful all right
Stephanie uh do you want to unmute
yourself and ask question yeah thanks
for the talk um I was wondering if you
can comment more on the connection to
the um natural gradient and remon
manifold you mentioned that's the angle
you came from at the beginning did you
divert from that or is it still the
same so many of the methods I've shown
you maybe I go back to a slide where I
can easily explain that can be
interpreted as
um maybe that's actually a good slide
yeah that's a good slide so many of the
methods can be interpreted as a natural
grade method and they can be interpreted
as a natural gradient method precisely
when this tmap here right this guy is um
symmetric right if this object really
here is an inner product on function
space then actually you're doing um a
natural gradient method or a ranan right
a ranan gradient descent method but
there is no need for t to be symmetric
if if you look at Saddle Point problems
and there was this example of Lon new
and competitive gradient descent then
this T is not um is not right and then
the method you get is not um a natural
gradient method is not the remanion
metric that you're using to design um
sort of your preconditioner for your
gradient so we switch to functions space
Viewpoint because it's it's more
General but everything with the natural
gradient descent is still valid is still
a good viewpoint does that answer your
question yes it does I might have some
followup questions later on I think I
wanted to adjust that a little bit but I
might shoot you an email if that's okay
yeah yeah happy to take emails of
course awesome great any other
questions um while someone has a
question I have another question so if
you go to slide 22
yes uh the size of the Matrix uh is
proportional to the
size of the anets right yes exactly
exactly the dimensionality of your
parameter space and I'm guessing that um
the performance of this uh gr gradient
descent uh will um depends on the size
of the onset as well I mean more the
better I guess I say that one more time
what will depend on the anets as well
the performance like the convergence
Behavior of this oh yeah so I mean if if
your answer is more expressive then sort
of you you expect right it's richer you
can you can um you can do better it will
always depend on on your specific
problem right so sometimes you need a
bigger anset sometimes a smaller is
sufficient oh okay so so I see the the
the balancing game here um so you need
more anets but if you increase the anet
then your Matrix becomes bigger and
bigger and you're dealing with the dense
Matrix so so it's harder to solve
numerically and so there just there
there must be some sweet spot between
those two balancing game um if you can
comment on that um from your
experience yeah
so I can say something I don't know if
this will be a perfect answer but um if
you're looking into you know simpler
problems um
where maybe your solution is not highly
oscillatory um but it's okay somewhat
smooth not to too complicated then we
found that um you can actually use
relatively small networks like the
default would probably right you set up
you set something up in jacks or pie
torch and you just go big because the
Frameworks will do it and your GPU can
do it but um often it might not even be
needed and then it's of course easier to
to um get it to run if you if you reduce
the size a bit and these algorithms play
nicely with that with Adam sometimes or
with first stochastic first order
methods sometimes you you you have the
feeling you need to go big with to make
it work okay but these also work work
quite well in a smaller Network in a
smaller um in a smaller regime but of
course if your if your function is
complicated if you're solving a many
electron sh equation there is no way you
can use a small Network and I think then
there is no way around um using some
approximation of these methods I mean as
a matter of fact this uh this KAC is I
think the gold standard for n network
based many electron shinger equations
um in this community they do not use um
PD pde operators in um in the precond
conditioner they use sort of an L2 based
version of that but they found this to
be crucial to optimize wave
[Music]
functions okay
um my next question is about the
chronical um you know K Factor you call
it um k k yes yeah yeah that's a
approximate um of the Jacobian the way
of computing so ex yeah exactly so
there's two approximations that we're
doing there's this Matrix G we do a plug
diagonal approximation of the
Matrix and then the diagonal blocks you
approximate them as chronica products so
it's it's it's a very aggressive
approximation of G yes okay and I'm
wondering if it can be since it is
approximate it can be used as a
preconditioner in I think it I think it
can and it's relatively high on our
to-do list to actually try that oh
okay oh yeah any other question from
audience you can unmute yourself and
then ask
questions well um if not let's thank our
speaker uh today um thank you so much is
in Europe right now how what time is it
there it's late 10 to 10 to 7 oh 10 to 7
oh okay not that bad I'm hope you no no
not not bad at all okay but I I I I
happens to know that mariia has a two
kids and very young four years old and
six month and um they need to go to bed
now yes they they'll require my help
they require your help but thank you so
much for having me in this wonderful
seminar thank you so much yeah yeah I
well I my last question would be before
we um head off hand um log off here um
obviously you know the National Lab they
deal with a very very large scale
problems and also the complexity is is
you multif physics and multi Fidelity
that sort of um the problem so you know
the it's still
questionable your method uh is how it is
applicable to directly to those complex
problems uh I'm sure there's a um way to
go I mean more research and more
development is is required so I'm I will
do my you know best of you know how we
can uh collaborate or um bring this you
know idea to the the multiphysics and
yes if if you are interested um if you
have high think these neuron network
based methods for pdes are especially
interesting for high dimensional pdes or
maybe potentially High dimensional
parameter spaces if it's
a if if you have a realistic problem um
yeah feel free to reach out we're
currently working on a on an easy to use
pych implementation of the of the KAC
method that I've shown you so please let
let me know if you're interested in
trying something out please reach out
okay well we'll do well thank you so
much for the wonderful talk Marias and
let's thank um let's Applause uh to our
great speaker today and that was very
nice and we learned a lot from you
Marius so we appreciate it so much bye
thank you bye